today on the matt walsh show leftists
across the country are melting into
puddles of sadness and rage over the
overturning of roe v wade many major
corporations are coming to their aid by
promising to pay for their employees
abortions this is supposed to be
empowering for women but it's exactly
the opposite we'll talk about why also
the supreme court is on a historic hot
streak with another major and majorly
correct decision coming down this
morning this one pertaining to prayer in
schools and amazon employees protest
johnny the walrus during the seattle
pride parade in our daily cancellation
many pro-abortion women are pledging to
practice abstinence in response to the
road decision i could not be a bigger
fan of that idea all of that plus a very
special treat for the sweet baby gang
that you'll have to see to believe trust
me today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
roe v wade has been overturned and uh
this battle now is finally leaving dc
and going to the grassroots it's not
over it's just changing venues in a
certain way and no group in america is
better positioned to fight this battle
than 40 days for life there are 1
million volunteers hold peaceful vigils
outside abortion facilities in a
thousand cities across the country in
fact most of their volunteers are
located in blue states such as
california where the lives of innocent
babies are most threatened and where
they're going to certainly be the most
needed now many former abortion facility
directors say that these vigils can
cause the abortion no show rate to
increase to as high as 75 which is a
major blow to the abortion business
these peaceful vigils have even led to
many closures of abortion facilities in
america nearly half of which
were in cities like san francisco
chicago and seattle which are of course
hardly pro-life areas 40 days for life
is effectively changing hearts and minds
in the grassroots to end abortion you
can check out their locations their
podcast and their free magazine at
40daysforlife.com
again for more information on 40 days
for life simply head to
40daysforlife.com
well the weekend after the dobbs
decision the final weekend of what has
been without question the greatest pride
month in history was marked with all the
frenzied hysteria and bloodthirsty
delirium that we were expecting
protesters raged in the streets in
arizona a full-on insurrection broke out
as rioters tried to break in to the
capitol building meanwhile democrats in
dc stoke the flames screaming that
democracy is dead the constitution is a
sham
all is lost now
because you know it'd be more difficult
to kill babies in some states on social
media an outpouring of rage and grief
and trauma from pro-aborts uh driven to
the edge of madness by the thought of
infants being born rather than butchered
some of the scenes have been i think
quite emotionally affecting uh and uh
here's just a brief compilation we put
together
get
angry
this is atrocious this is war on women
how
dare the supreme court do this
you kavanagh [ __ ] you gorsuch for a
lying under health when you were
confirmed saying that you believed that
this was settled women will die but as
long as it fits your christian god
narrative it must be correct
[Music]
all the human rights are going to start
falling down
all right lgbtq plus community we're
next on the chopping block and birth
control
[Music]
and possibly interracial marriage
[Music]
so pretty much we're going
the only thing that's gonna have rights
in this country is
white men and guns
this is about the woman who tried to
have a baby so bad and ended up having a
miscarriage who now has to go stand on
trial
if we don't stand up now and do
something about this the handmaid's tale
is going to be more than just a show
and
i am sick
i
how do i look at my daughters
and tell them that they're growing up in
an amazing place when they're not i love
to travel and spend money like i love to
spend money but if you are a red state
and
you have anti-abortion laws not only
will i not visit your state
and not spend my money there but i will
also not be sending my children there to
college
and they will not be spending any money
there either
i think that if you can leave the
country you should i think if you're of
childbearing age
and you can leave the country you should
always delicious
you know
i have to be honest with you watching
that last clip
i really do feel bad uh for whoever was
filming it
because that was not a selfie the camera
actually followed her as she writhed
about having a temper tantrum that would
give my two-year-old something to aspire
to i'm just wondering whether she told
the person behind the camera that she
wanted to grab some footage of her
psychotic break
like did she tell them that ahead of
time or was this all a surprise i don't
know
but unintelligible guttural screaming
comes in many different forms of course
and um we saw a lot of that sort of
thing on cable news where the tantrums
were slightly less ear piercing but
certainly not any more coherent aoc
who's been doing a full media tour
vomiting her half-baked abortion
opinions in front of any camera she can
find appear on nbc on sunday to call for
the impeachment
of all of the justices who issued an
opinion she doesn't like much
they can now lie
to duly elected members of the united
states senate in order to secure supreme
court uh nomin confirmations and and and
seats on the supreme court this is what
we're saying lying in a confirmation
hearing is an impeachable offense i
believe so okay i believe so i believe
lying under oath is an impeachable
offense
i believe that violating federal law in
not disclosing income from political
organizations as clarence thomas
did years ago is also potentially an
impeachable offense i believe that um
that not recusing
from cases that one clearly has family
members involved in
with very deep violations of conflict of
interest are also impeachable offenses
now of course it's not true that the
justices lied under oath okay they
avoided the roe question they didn't lie
about it it's also particularly funny i
think that the left is acting betrayed
and heartbroken by especially justice
kavanaugh
you know voting against their interests
all they did was falsely accuse him of
being a serial gang rapist so how could
he be so disloyal to them after that
this is how the left views things though
of course you know they can they can
treat you like dirt try to ruin your
life and at the end of it all they still
expect your undying and unquestioned
fealty and obedience
they don't know how to handle it when
they get anything less than that
corporate america has jumped into the
action too we should note one of the
first out of the gate was dick's
sporting goods a company that sells
products to the sorts of people who hunt
and fish and play sports but markets
itself to the sorts of people who've
never done any of those things
mere hours after the decision was
announced on friday dicks issued a
statement from the ceo declaring their
intention to facilitate and fund
the execution of their employees
children the memo from dick's head
lauren hobart read in part
in response to today's ruling we are
announcing that if the state you live in
restricts access to abortion
dick's sporting goods will provide up to
four thousand dollars in travel uh
reimburse reimbursement to travel to the
nearest location where that care is
legally available the benefit will be
provided to any teammate spouse or
dependent enrolled in our medical plan
along with one support person
translation
rather than give birth to another
dependent
we will pay you to kill him
and dix was not the only company to make
this
generous offer many other major
corporations also put prices on the
heads of their employees children a
citigroup sales force facebook yelp
netflix uber jpmorgan chase wells fargo
goldman sachs to name a few all have
extended this charity to the hirelings
on their payroll
and the left has applauded this you know
they've applauded this as allyship and
they could not be happier that now
abortion will remain an intimate and
private decision made by a woman her
doctor
and the multinational corporation she
works for
because everyone knows that you should
never trust these evil greedy billion
dollar capitalist businesses
unless they're offering to fund your
abortion tourism in which case i mean
you can assume that it's nothing but an
act of kind-hearted philanthropy
but you know someone who's um
slightly less trusting
might think that there's
something other than pure benevolence
driving this
two other things specifically
one is the standard corporate instinct
to virtue signal at every opportunity
and since we live in a decaying virtuous
society a company can virtue signal by
bragging about all the infanticides it's
planning to fund
the other factor is even simpler though
um profit margins
because if you're a generic cubicle
jockey working for jpmorgan chase or
goldman sachs or whatever your
employer's bottom line is better served
by shelling out a few thousand bucks to
pay for an abortion
than by losing you for months at a time
or maybe forever when you have a child
these employers want all of their
nameless vassals on the payroll to come
to work
do whatever task is required of them
punch out
and come back the next day
anything that interrupts this workflow
anything that pulls a worker away from
her job anything that distracts her or
causes her to focus on anything other
than the data she's supposed to be
punching into her computer
all of that
is an obstacle that her employer would
rather just get rid of and this includes
especially includes her children
now here i think in this um rather bleak
dystopian spectacle of major
corporations incentivizing employees to
murder their children
we see the modern notion of women's
empowerment laid bare
because for years we've been told that
um a woman is liberated and fulfilled
when she leaves her home and her family
and becomes a hired servant for some
corporation
the institution of the family stifles
and oppresses her so she can find her
freedom within a larger profit-driven
institution
there rather than attending to the needs
of her family she can attend to the
needs of upper management
and this is supposed to be the pinnacle
of human happiness and achievement and a
far more joyful and luxurious life than
the one that she might have had at home
um
and what we discover now is that all of
this is and always was a lie
now of course there's nothing wrong with
having a job okay i i have one
but this romanticized vision of the
corporate world
and the claim that working a
nine-to-five job is superior in every
way to working in the home
is false and empty
and ultimately absurd
and nothing could make that more clear
nothing could better reveal
the stark reality of the situation than
these companies encouraging their
employees to violently liberate
themselves from motherhood so that they
can stay on the clock
and at their desk
driving revenue
now yes a woman will be far happier if
she embraces motherhood
rather than shedding the blood of her
own offspring in order to avoid it
but these companies aren't concerned
with their employees happiness
or their wholeness or
fulfillment
they care about the bottom line
and they will kill
or rather pay for you to kill
in order to protect it
and this is what they call empowerment
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
and i'll be honest guys sometimes this
job gets uh really difficult all day
long i watch debunk and cancel stupid
people it's a grind and some days my
producers make me sit behind this desk
for hours on end watching purple-haired
weirdos attempt to explain their
gender-neutral pronouns to me it's no
easy task and the only way that i've
found to cope with it and all this
torture is with hello hello is the
number one christian prayer app in the
u.s it's like calm or head space but
rooted in catholic faith as opposed to
the religion of leftism hallow offers
over 5 000 audio guided prayers
meditation and christian music tracks
some of the most popular prayers include
the daily rosary gospel reading and the
daily psalm with [ __ ] of bishop baron
and uh and many others as well hallow
helps me find peace and calm throughout
the day even as crazy left just yell at
me through a tiny screen it's still it
centers me back you know in a very real
way let hallow help you find your piece
dude go to hallow.com matt walsh and get
an extended three-month free trial
during which you'll have access to all 5
000 plus meditation and prayers that's
hallow.com matt walsh for three months
free reclaim your peace in this crazy
world download hallow today
um you know it's been uh it's been as i
said a great pride month a lot of big
uh major achievements and milestones and
everything had had a personal one in my
life which is that um on instagram we
went over 500 000 followers on instagram
and uh a lot of great content over on my
instagram page
i think i haven't looked at it in a few
months but uh you should definitely go
follow me on instagram if you haven't
yet
that's a great pitch
you know i was kind of making light uh
before of of the leftists upset about
roe v wade being overturned but i did
want to play one here's one reaction
that actually does
you know it does hurt a little bit this
one this one hurt me
the twitch streamer uh twitch streamer i
think is what they're called pokemane
says that she's leaving the country and
she's not the only one there are a bunch
of leftists now many of them on twitch
who are leaving the country because of
roe v wade being overturned and just
just listen to this
yes
the roe vs wade
news is
absolutely terrible
i tweeted about it irt a couple things i
faved a couple things it's just tough
because
[Music]
what more can we even say at this point
we've said it all
it's depressing
i booked a ticket back to canada like
anna
i just don't want to imagine a country
without pokemane
i just i can't imagine i i woke up this
morning
and it felt
they're pointless that there's no reason
to get out of bed and carry on without
pokeman maine
i wander through the countryside crying
out for pokemane but she was nowhere to
be found because she had moved back to
canada
along with all the rest a lot a lot of
them saying they're moving to canada uh
a lot of uh we get a lot of leftists who
are in red states saying they're moving
out they're done
and some would say that this is just a
major added bonus
of having roe v wade overturned so it's
a win upon win
uh upside upon upside it's a great thing
one other reaction worth playing for you
this is anna navarro who used to pretend
to be a conservative i don't even know
if she still does anymore if she's still
if she still is keeping up that act or
not in fact she's one of uh you know one
of these so-called conservatives bill
crystal's another and there are others
um and you know they they are on cable
news a lot and
they've
decided at some point in the last few
years that um
not only are they do they hate donald
trump and this is where it all started
like they hated donald trump and so then
they went over to the left while still
pretending to be on the right but
they've also decided that they've
adopted all of the left's positions on
everything including being pro-abortion
and none of these people have explained
why they changed their mind on abortion
they just did and uh
have never been asked to explain that
so anna navarro is one of them and and
here's the um
the reason that she gave this is on cnn
right after the decision was made and
supreme court overturned roe v wade
here's the the pitch that she gives for
abortion listen to this
i have not anybody could tell you what
you need to do with your life or with
your uterus and because i have a family
with a lot of special needs kids i have
a brother who's 57 and has the mental
and motor skills of a one-year-old and i
know what that means financially
emotionally physically for a family and
i know not all families can do it and i
have a step granddaughter who was born
with a down syndrome and you know what
it is very difficult in florida to get
services
well that's
quite horrifying of course what she's
saying is that well i have family
members who have special needs i have a
family member with down syndrome and so
therefore it would be better off if they
were dead i mean that's what she's
saying
now she's come out after the fact to
clarify and say she's being taken out of
context or whatever but you you heard
the whole context there there's no
context that will rescue you from what
you actually said
and she of course is not the only one on
the left making this case we're hearing
this over and over again
uh in fact i just responded to somebody
on twitter it looks like they
well they just deleted it but uh
verified account some journalist
saying that uh well what about
you know we get rid of abortion and
think about all the kids that are going
to be in foster care now
and the way and what she said was would
you would you really go to the child in
foster care and say to him uh well at
least you're alive
and and yeah actually that is part of
the message
to anyone who's in a difficult position
or suffering that it's good to be alive
that there's hope
what else would your message be
are you going to go to the child in
foster care and say it would be better
if you were dead
is that your message
is that your message to a child with
down syndrome in your own family
that's you're better off dead well that
is the message that's what the left is
saying
uh because
and this is the this is eugenics
that there's there are some lives that
are just not worth living
and on the left they're considered to be
kind of the dregs of humanity
if you have special needs if you're in
foster care
you're a strain on the system it'd just
be better if you were dead maybe better
off to just kill you
the only thing at this point that the
left stops themselves from doing is
openly advocating that we kill those
people now who have already been born
but
that's coming down the line
that's a that's a logical extension of
the argument that they're making
after all if what you're saying is that
the the seven-year-old in foster care is
better off dead
that's not very far from arguing that we
might as well just kill all the kids in
foster care well you just said they're
better off dead their lives aren't worth
living
no either you cherish life or you don't
either you think life is worth living or
you don't
um either you think that every human
life has potential
and every person has the right to live
their life and uh and and have a chance
at
you know fulfilling that potential at
least either you believe that or you
don't
and if you don't believe that then the
consequences are quite dark
as we're seeing now
uh one other thing that i thought this
was a kind of funny this was
ian miles chong
posted this on twitter this is uh
someone on the left on reddit
trying to organize people to go
pro pro abortion people to to get
together and go into the rural areas to
go after the uh pro-lifers this is what
they say
the radical christians are found in the
rural areas their towns are defenseless
they have almost no cops and their
firemen are volunteers they have to
borrow cops and firemen from neighboring
jurisdictions miles away in order to
handle anything big and they think
they're safe out there forget burning
cities cities are on our side it's time
for rural areas to feel the heat you
show up 100 deep in every rural town in
a 50 mile radius intent on revolution
you'll crash their system and make them
pay and if you all think i'm kidding i'm
dead serious this was caused by backward
ass rural conservatives operating out of
a christianized worldview they were the
ones who voted for trump and 16. these
disillusioned redneck white trash brute
blue collar types who flipped massively
for the gop punish them punish their
towns
um
and every rural person
who hears that is just thinking to
themselves yeah please try it please try
i moved from a rural area last year and
the idea that um country folk are
defenseless
what i can tell you is if you live out
in the country you hear gunshots
all day and night
but it's a different kind of gunshot
it's not like the kind of gunshot you
hear if you live in an urban area and
it's because you know people on the on
the street corner are shooting each
other over drugs or whatever no this is
out in the country they're shooting day
and night because it's like target
practice they're shooting just for fun
in their big backyards because in the
country you actually get to have a yard
with grass and stuff
or they're out hunting so everyone is
armed to the teeth
they have guns and they know how to use
them
so yeah go ahead and give that a shot
get 100 antifa folks together and go out
into the country for your revolution and
we'll see how that goes make sure to
live stream it you know i'd like to see
how that plays out
um all right
moving on to this the supreme court is
just on a roll right now i think this is
uh the greatest
series of supreme court decisions in
history i'm not sure that anything even
comes close
so um this is from the daily wire on
monday morning the supreme court of the
united states ruled in kennedy versus uh
bremerton school district that a public
high school football coach
in the state of washington had his first
amendment rights violated after he was
placed on administrative leave by the
school district and banned from
participating in the football program
for praying on the field after games in
view of students
and the majority opinion was authored by
justice neil gorsuch it was a 6-3
decision they were saying that his
rights were violated that he did indeed
have the right to pray on the field and
to punish him for it was a violation of
his rights
gorsuch wrote
here a government entity sought to
punish an individual for engaging in a
brief quiet personal religious
observance doubly protected by the free
exercise and free speech clauses of the
first amendment and the only meaningful
jurisdiction justification the
government offered for its reprisal
rested on a mistaken view that it had a
duty to ferret out and suppress
religious observances even as it allows
comparable secular speech the
constitution neither mandates nor
tolerates that kind of discrimination
this one's pretty obvious the only
concerning thing here obviously is that
three justices
actually thought
that a football coach doesn't have the
right to pray
okay that's the concerning thing
here's the just to remind everybody
the actual text of the first amendment
congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion or prohibiting
the free exercise thereof or abridging
the freedom of state speech or of the
press or of the right of people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances okay
that's what the the
first amendment says
the only limitation
if we can call it that
placed around religion is that congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion
in other words congress cannot make a uh
cannot establish a state religion
so
you know my dream of being a theocratic
fascist dictator well that's that's that
can't happen within our current system
but that's okay because the plan always
was to destroy the system and just
appoint me the you know the emperor of
of the hemisphere uh but as long as we
have this system in place that's that's
the rule
anything outside of that though
when it comes to the exercise of
religion is not any kind of infringement
of the first amendment
so when they here's what we have to ask
ourselves
when a football coach
um
prays
on the field
with with other players who who are
there voluntarily he's not forcing them
to be there he didn't say that you have
to pray or show your uh
fealty to the christian faith in order
to be on the team he didn't say that
but when he's
choosing to pray is that him
establishing a state religion
no
is he congress
or even a member of congress no he's
just a private individual
so no this this falls
pretty clearly under the free exercise
clause of the first amendment
which means that to stop him from doing
it is infringing on the first amendment
i mean just think about we're so used to
hearing this argument from the left that
you you know you get numb to it after a
while but just think about how perverse
and ridiculous it is
to claim that you're infringing on the
first amendment
by praying
what
the first amendment exists
in part to protect your right to do
exactly that
so this was clearly the right the right
decision and there's just
the argument on the other side of this
is uh grounded
in a total mutilation of the first
amendment
and what the first amendment is meant to
actually
protect all right let's move to this uh
there's a whole lot going on today so
we've got to move quickly through some
of these boris johnson prime minister of
the uk was interviewed by jake tapper
and there was a great exchange where
tapper tried to get johnson to agree
that american democracy was destroyed on
january 6th
was devastated but instead johnson
reveals that
people in other countries apparently
aren't in their historical their
hysterical doomsday cult you know the
one that jake tapper the rest of the
media is in uh people in other countries
aren't necessarily in that same cult and
so it led to this exchange which i
thought was pretty entertaining listen
to this
we're here at the g7 a gathering of the
world's leading democracies when i talk
to friends in canada the uk australia
and elsewhere people express concern
about the united states as the united
states about the united states in terms
of our ability in our institutions to
to thrive and continue after what
happened
uh with the election of 2020. they worry
that
democracy is on life support in the
united states people might not know this
about you but you were born in the
united states and until recently i was
and i was i was i was born in new york
city uh this was a fantastic place jake
where were you where were you born in
new york where was staten island all
right okay i was like i was born in new
york general hospital remember are you
worried at all do you know i want to say
this to the people of the united states
i'm not i think that i i'll just get
back to the what i've been trying to say
to you throughout this interview i think
that uh reports of the death of
democracy in the united states are
grossly grossly exaggerated uh america
is a shining city on a hill and
for me
and it will continue to be so
and i think that uh
the mere fact that uh joe biden has
stepped up to the plate in the way that
uh that he has uh shows that the
instincts of america are still very much
in the right place and yeah look i mean
there were there were some uh weird and
and kind of unattractive scenes
uh back in the you know died i mean it
was pretty serious it was pretty weird i
i would i wouldn't do that that wasn't
weird i mean looking from the outside it
was pretty weird but i don't believe
that american democracy is under serious
threat far from it i continue to believe
that america is the greatest global
guarantor of democracy and freedom
yeah it's actually the best possible one
word description of january 6th like in
reality what actually happened uh it was
weird it was it was very that's what
that's the truth it was weird now jake
tapper lies and said people died uh one
person died and that was ashley babbitt
who was killed by a capital police
officer of course but
jake tapper doesn't even count her like
they don't she doesn't count any time
they're talking about the death toll of
january 6 they're not counting her she
didn't exist as far as they're concerned
so um he's just making up other stuff
nobody else died as um or was killed you
know through violence on january 6 or
died as a result of january 6. um
but the best one word description
actually is the one boris johnson gives
it there which is it was definitely
weird it was a very weird thing like it
was just weird okay i mean you've when
you've got a guy in a in a buffalo
helmet
marching through the capitol people are
taking selfies at nancy pelosi's desk
it's a weird thing
but did it destroy our democracy um
no it didn't
and this is really hard this is why jake
tapper he was you could tell he was
quite shocked he kept trying to get
boris johnson to agree with him no no
but it was it was the worst thing ever
right it wasn't the worst thing that
ever happened in history it's one of the
great historical tragedies wasn't it
don't you think that
so he's shocked that boris johnson won't
go along with it because they don't they
just they don't
it's it's a cliche
at this point to talk about how
the media
and the leftist elite are in a bubble
and are insulated like it sounds like a
cliche but it is also true
that they exist in this insulated bubble
and um
they just don't understand or realize
how other people view
anything
especially how other people view them
they don't understand it
all right let's move to this
this is from bloomberg
it says a group of amazon.com and uh
incorporated employees plan to march in
seattle's pride parade on sunday so this
was an article that went out
before the pride parade which happened
yesterday
but this gives a little bit of context
of something that happened at this pride
parade so it says the
amazon players plan to march in
seattle's pride parade on sunday to
protest the online retailer sale of
books that they consider
anti-transgender an action that
threatens to erode the company's image
as an inclusive employer in recent
months several hundred staffers have
been pushing the e-commerce giant to ban
books like irreversible damage the
transgender craze seducing our daughters
which is by abigail schreier uh and as
i've said one of the most important
books of this century if you've never
read that book you should read it
they say that such titles dehumanize
trans people and dismiss their
identities as mental disorders which
runs counter to the recommendations of
almost every major medical group
employees say the books could confuse
vulnerable teens and their parents who
turn to amazon seeking information
and another target is johnny the walrus
a children's book by conservative
commentator matt walsh about a boy who
thinks he's a marine mammal the boy's
mother caving the pressure from the
internet people quote unquote feeds him
worms and takes him to a saw wielding
doctor who suggests turning his hands
and feet into fins that is a
pretty correct summation of the plot of
that book a spokesperson for the titles
publisher of the daily wire owned dw
books applauded amazon for dismissing
demands by its woke employees adding
that quote with nearly 100 000 copies
sold on amazon alone it's clear that
there is a huge demand for johnny the
walrus by amazon customers and we are
thrilled with the book's massive success
um
so we didn't get the as expected we
didn't get the apology statement from
daily wire i would be pretty shocked by
that so then the the uh
pride parade happens and the amazon
employees show up and uh i was really
hoping and rooting that they'd have some
signs with maybe images of johnny the
walrus i was hoping for like a sign
with a with a trans walrus you know
circled and crossed out or something now
we didn't get that but here is what we
did get instead at the pride parade go
ahead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right there's holding signs saying
no hate at amazon
which i'm i'm fine with that message by
the way i agree
which is why there's nothing remotely
hateful
about johnny the walrus or about my
other best-selling book which is what is
a woman in book form which you can buy
at amazon and as it just so happens we
found out this weekend 360 platform
provides recruiters and sources at
companies i'm just listening okay he's
not saying anything important all right
we can turn that off so that's it that's
all they just marched with that banner
huge disappointment there but uh that
was the disappointment
um the good part is that we found out
over the weekend that what is a woman my
book was a woman uh was officially you
know made it officially onto the amazon
bestseller list for the week and made it
on the publisher weekly publishers
weekly bestseller list wall street
journal and pretty much every bestseller
list except for the new york times
because new york times has decided that
basically no daily wire book is allowed
to make it on their list anymore
that started with michael knowles in his
book speechless so really i blame him
and ever since then
no other daily wire book is allowed to
be on the new york times bestseller
johnny the walrus we sold like
what i don't even know what it was 50 60
000 copies in a week or something crazy
like that and we still didn't make it on
the new york times bestsellers but we
were on every other bestseller list for
what is a woman
including this is pretty funny the
seattle times this is the seattle pride
march and the seattle times best seller
list we made that one also so you can go
to amazon.com right now and uh pick up
that book
now
you know it's funny too that they lump
you know they lump me in with abigail
schreier and they lump in my books with
abigail schreier's books
but um
you know
my
approach
i will admit
can sometimes be um a little
provocative you know
and uh and i'll i'll admit that about
myself
even on johnny the walrus we never even
mention anything about trans people i
mean it's simply a story
of uh of a boy identifying as a walrus
that's all a lovely fanciful tale but in
general i'll admit that i take that
approach abigail schreier does not
and um her book
irreversible damage all all it simply
does is document
this
craze as it says in the subtitle uh
overtaking you know adolescent girls it
takes this phenomenon
which is that over the course of just a
few years transgender identification
skyrocketed to astronomical levels among
adolescent girls in particular and so
abigail schreier is noticing that in the
book and then trying to figure out why
that is happening
and in fact schreier i don't want to
misrepresent her view here but
she
i don't think and certainly not in the
book but even just herself individually
she doesn't take any
issue necessarily with the fundamental
premise of transgenderism like i do i do
take an issue with the fundamental
premise she does not at least not
publicly and i don't know how she feels
personally one way or another but and
the book doesn't
like the book actually doesn't say that
it's necessarily impossible
for a man to be a woman
the book just doesn't give an opinion on
that one way or another
um all it does is talk about this
phenomenon as it affects
children
especially girls
and that's hate speech also
because when it comes to the the trans
mafia their message is clear you're not
allowed to talk about this
all of the you know
you can't even notice these problems
you cannot mention them to notice them
or mention them is hate speech
elsewhere at the seattle pride parade we
should note the uh boy scouts were on
the scene
i think we have the footage here
maybe we do yeah okay there are the boy
scouts
and uh they're marching along with
american flags but also pride flags as
they were put in the pride parade
and uh it's probably not a coincidence
by the way that they have the kids
holding the pride flags even higher than
the american flags and there are also as
you can see when they march by there are
a lot more pride flags than american
flags
oh there we go
[Applause]
so pride flags
greatly outnumbering the american flags
but
that doesn't make a difference i mean
the fact that you're putting kids in a
pride parade in the first place is
obviously
demented
and i can't play footage of this but
maybe you could just take my word for it
or you could look it up online if you
really wanted to the fact check me maybe
this was one time where you won't fact
check me but there were fully naked
adults in this parade marching alongside
um the the boy scouts marching in the
same parade as the boy scouts were fully
naked adults there was a there was a
whole team of um
nude groomers on bicycles
just cycling around
in front of kids who are in the crowd
and also alongside kids who are in the
parade
and then afterwards there's all this
footage of uh a lot of these people they
they gathered at a fountain downtown in
seattle and they were just fully nude
adults like prancing around in the
fountain
with with little kids there
but this is they're not groomers right
that's a conspiracy theory that's a it's
a homophobic conspiracy theory to say
that these people are groomers
getting fully naked in front of kids
and prancing around kids fully naked is
to call that grooming is is nothing but
a it's an anti-gay conspiracy theory
right
that makes a lot of sense
i wanted to mention this not not quite
as important as some of the other issues
we talked about but i've had this on the
docket for a few days so big news the
lord of the rings series for amazon
they just announced will have female
orcs
so there's going to be representation
you know we know that this is this is
absolutely going to be and i've been
telling you this from the beginning from
the moment they announced this lord of
the rings series for for amazon i told
you just give up all hope
abandon all hope ye who enter here when
it comes to this if you're a fan of the
lord of the rings they are going to
butcher it and they are going to wokify
it there's no way that they won't it's
impossible that they won't
and so we're already getting a preview
of that based on the fact that they're
um bragging
about having female orc representation
in lord of the rings and i'm just
wondering where else can we get
representation
like if they make another tremor sequel
i want a female gay and trans giant
man-eating worms in that if they make a
tremor sequel they should do a hills
have eyes remake and make sure there's
greater lgbt representation among the
deformed incestuous cannibals
i want another remake of the thing
but the thing is
non-binary i want that also
i guess we already have that it's called
tick-tock but we need all that
one other thing before we get to the
comment section a very special comment
section i should note you're not going
to miss it uh we never talked about this
on friday either but we need to camila
harris's team
in an increasingly desperate effort to
make her seem human and relatable they
released this video of her
shooting a basketball
and making the shot on the first try
really impressive let's watch this video
first
[Applause]
look at that and she puts her hands up
she says yeah did you ever doubt me uh
first shot i made it
or maybe not because then the full video
came out and uh let's just take a look
at the full video or at least some of it
anyway
here's here's what happened before she
actually made the shot go ahead and play
this
all right she starts by she's standing
on the court cackling for no reason as
we might expect
and then someone hands her
okay
very poor dribbler you would expect her
to have better ball handling skills
based on
well never mind but
you know she has the hand-eye
coordination and agility of a
malfunctioning robot
this is just who let her do this like
kamela's team
hates her and we know that
because otherwise they would have
stopped this from happening
takes another shot
uh at least she made contact with
something that time
[Applause]
how many shots is this that was two
shots she missed
so third shot terrible form look at this
form
what is that what up almost
you know the sad part is that she would
still be a top three scorer in the wnba
wnba recruiters are watching this like
man this kid has potential
anyway okay so we get the point
to quote joe biden you ain't black
all right let's uh let's get now to a
very special edition
of the comment section
[Music]
have you ever looked at your credit card
statement and been shocked by the
interest rate did you know that you
could actually roll all of your credit
card debt into one monthly payment at a
lower fixed interest rate you can lower
your interest rate and save with a
credit card consolidation loan from
light stream rates start at 5.73 apr
with auto pay and excellent credit plus
the rate is fixed so it will never go up
over the life of the loan and that gives
you stability uh you can certainly use
some of that in this economic climate
you can get a loan from five thousand to
a hundred thousand dollars and there are
absolutely no fees at all you can even
get your money as soon as the day you
apply lightstream believes that people
with good credit deserve a better loan
experience and that's exactly what they
deliver just for my listeners though you
can apply now to get a special interest
rate discount discount and save even
more than that the only way to get this
discount is to go to
lightstream.com
walsh that's
t r e l-i-g-h-t
m.com walsh
subject to credit approval rates range
from 5.73 apr to 19.99 apr and include
0.5 auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit
lightstream.com livestream.comwalsh for
more information
all right so a few months ago while in
the throes of insanity i announced that
uh once we crossed a million views i
would celebrate with an interpretive
dance
performed for
the sweet baby gang
and the next day having come to my
senses and regained full consciousness i
beg to be relieved of this obligation
and to be released from my promise but
my audience is full of sadists who
demand to see me humiliate myself for
their amusement
and uh so be it um
i am a man of my word
and so as promised and then demanded
i did in fact personally myself
and this is really me 100
i did perform an interpretive dance to
mark this momentous occasion and now we
will show you this piece of art this
work of of staggering tragic beauty
where i
personally myself
dance for all of you
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
well
there it is
uh what is it
what just happened
why did it happen
nobody will ever
really know for sure
i will say though that's uh and this is
just just a little bit of uh if i could
get serious for just a second you know
that through that dance
expressing myself through the movement
of my body in that way
um i can tell you that i felt for the
first time
at home and at peace in the universe um
i got in touch with
something deep and primal and raw
i fell in love with with life with
nature
with dance
well june has been one of the biggest
months in daily wire history and also in
the history of the country as well
and we still have a week to go my
documentary what is a woman has a 97 uh
score on rotten tomatoes and over 5 000
ratings the book what is a woman which
released only 13 days ago is already as
mentioned a national bestseller we also
had our premiere of the blockbuster uh
summer film tara on the prairie starring
mma fighter turned actress gina carano
we proved once and for all that
hollywood cannot cancel you if you don't
let them cancel you and now this week on
wednesday june 29th at 8 p.m eastern
we'll we will have our backstage live at
the ryman we did it uh about a year ago
it was a lot of fun it's going to be
even better this time you'll see your
favorite daily wire hosts like you've
never seen them before talk taking on
the cultural and political topics of the
day
describing it doesn't really do it
justice though so just take a look
welcome to the daily wire backstage live
at the famous ryman auditorium
it was amazing we were in the presence
of greatness the energy of having
everyone on the same page was amazing if
your family member is still waiting for
fauci to give them permission to leave
their house it might be time to cut that
off
i'm actually pretty excited to meet all
of them i love everybody's opinion
individually i don't have a favorite i
like them all i had found out a way
to make football players cry in high
school my high school experience
i'm just excited to be here and be
surrounded by like-minded people and to
just you know feel that energy who
should we remove from office yeah one
politician the most powerful politician
in the country dr fauci
we're doing culture here i'm so thrilled
to see this happening if they say to
half of the country you can't that half
of the country needs to say screw you we
will backstage live happens right here
in nashville on june 29th get your
tickets now
so tune in to backstage live at the
ryman this wednesday june 29th at 8 pm
ester eastern and become a daily wire
member by going to dailywire.com walsh
and use codewalls for 25 off your
membership that's dailywire.com
walsh today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today we quite happily cancel hookup
culture um but i'm not the one canceling
it not by myself anyway for today i
joined hands with pro-abortion feminists
in delivering this cancellation
ironically the anti-hookup culture cause
makes for strange bedfellows so in
response to the termination of roe v
wade the reaction from abortion
enthusiasts has stretched across the
whorishness spectrum in many cities
around the country protesters who skimp
on clothing but never on meals have
defiantly paraded their half-naked
bodies around oftentimes twerking
aggressively like some kind of weird and
ghastly mating ritual here was the scene
in dallas for example check it out
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if anything could ever make me mourn the
end of row uh it would be a scene like
that
but row itself was such a monstrosity
that even these sorts of nightmarish
spectacles are a cost worth paying
watching that video i don't regret that
roe was overturned but i do perhaps
regret that i am not blind but in any
case here we have women wielding their
sexuality as a weapon it's just not
clear what the weapon is supposed to
accomplish or what it's supposed to
destroy besides their dignity and my
appetite but on the other end of the
spectrum
some pro-abortion women have gone an
entirely different route rather than
bending over and presenting themselves
to the public like a dog in heat these
women have promised a sex strike they're
saying that they will for a period of
time or maybe forever
stop having sex with random men in order
to punish those random men
for the supreme court's decision
it's not clear what these men have done
to deserve that punishment but i'm sure
they're grateful for it anyway in one
popular video on tick tock an abortion
fan lays out the plan specifically
listen
hear me out what if we withhold sex
i'm not kidding what if we use our most
powerful protesting option
and withhold sex from penises
until this is made right
i love the i'm not kidding part because
she the idea of withholding sex of like
not having sex or abstaining
to hurt it's so you know of not having
sex with random people all the time it's
so shocking to her that she has to pause
she said
here's an idea what if we don't have sex
for a while
no seriously i'm not kidding seriously
guys withhold sex from penises she says
because that's how she views the sexual
act as an exchange between two sets of
faceless nameless body parts
the new york post talked to some
protesters at a demonstration in new
york city about their sex strike plans
and they all hit on similar themes
reading now it says
big apple abortion protesters were in
support of a sex strike saturday as
abstinence started trending on twitter
in the wake of the supreme court's
decision to overturn roe v wade quote if
you're a man who won't get a vasectomy
even though it's reversible and you're
not out on the streets fighting for my
rights uh you don't deserve to have sex
with me brianna campbell a 24 year old
emt told the post caroline healy a 22
year old event coordinator also
questioned why sex was more important
than women's rights quote i think it's
absolutely valid for us to be
withholding the holy grail that men seem
to think is important she told the post
um quote women of america take the
pledge because scotus overturned roe v
wade we cannot take the risk of an
unintended pregnancy therefore we will
not have sex with any men including our
husbands unless we are trying to become
pregnant one twitter user wrote i live
in new york quote and i am double
furious with the supreme court i want to
find people who are coordinating a mass
sex strike
that is our power one woman raged
women have the power here no more sex
until abortion rights are federal law
another said quote perhaps a sex strike
also known as abstinence would help the
men folk to be all in on the women's
rights issue
well um
i am a man folk and i can say that your
decision to abstain from sex in response
to overturning roe
definitely does not make me lament the
overturning of roe it is rather a
significant bonus this is like this is
like getting upgraded to first class and
then finding a 100 bill under your seat
okay this is this is again upside upon
upside win upon win
and we're not done winning yet because
back on tick tock the pro-abortion
luminaries of that app have been even
more explicit about their ultimate
intentions
reading from an article on insider
published a few weeks before the roe
decision was officially announced it
says quote some women say they will deny
casual sex if they do not have abortion
rights after news broke the supreme
court
is poised to overturn roe v wade quote
in case you're a man who doesn't care
about roe v wade just know that if
abortion gets banned hookup culture will
be absolutely decimated according to one
tick tock user which has received more
than 1.2 million views in a single day
what women
what woman would have mediocre sex with
a drunk rando if he could potentially
father their child she continued noting
that the video is directed at all the
pro-life men who love plan b
the clip drew more than 263 000 likes
and more than 3 100 comments with many
users agreeing with her assessment
quote omg i'm entering my celibacy era a
user commented below to which the video
creator replied that she had the same
thought the second the news came out
we all need to collectively agree to
never touch another man again if it gets
overturned
another user declared that they were
deleting all dating apps as we speak in
another video which received 12 000
views fitness influencer nikki cox said
that the debate surrounding roe v wade
isn't just for women quote since about
75 of men only care about sex and money
i hope they know this roe v wade
decision could destroy hookup culture
and leave them paying 18 years of child
support she wrote
now one thing you'll notice is that over
the past few days
the pretense has been completely dropped
abortion advocates are no longer
pretending that abortion is anything but
a form of birth control
of course prior to the overturning of
roe they bristled at the suggestion that
anyone would ever use abortion as birth
control
now amid their hysteria they've
forgotten about that talking point
altogether that's for the best
because abortion in the lion's share of
cases has been used as a means to
divorce sex from its natural
consequences
otherwise known as birth control
this has been the left's primary
undertaking it's animating principle
it's great commission
i think quite possibly this is more than
anything else the core of leftism itself
and that is
the desire to reduce sex
down to its mere physical sensations
they want to remove everything from the
sexual act except the physical pleasure
everything else goes away take away love
take away joy devotion fidelity they
want intimacy without intimacy take away
commitment familiarity emotional
fulfillment
and most of all or at least first of all
they seek to strip from sex it's
life-giving capacities
the problem they always run into though
is that it's not actually possible to
permanently remove all of those things
from sex
and if ever they do encounter somebody
usually a man who's actually achieved
the goal of engaging the sexual act
without any emotions or any sense of
responsibility or any commitment at all
wrapped up into it
they'll hate that man and organize a me
too mob to come after it
because as usual they don't much like
the frankensteins they've created but in
most cases
totally emotionless and consequence-free
sex is an illusion
the attempt to neuter sex in this way to
turn it into a meaningless interaction
between nameless sets of sex organs
just creates a mass orgy of confusion
and despair otherwise known as hookup
culture
and yet even though hookup culture
utterly fails to make anybody happy
and instead succeeds in making everyone
lonely and miserable
it was still able to linger on as long
as it had abortion as its fail-safe
because abortion was supposed to be sort
of the fortress
defending the individual from the
natural results of their own choices
meanwhile inside that fortress everybody
is sad and confused and leading small
pathetic self-centered little lives
but but that's the way it was set up
and now the fortress has been weakened
there are cracks and gaps all around
where consequence
in the form of new life
can rush in
some pro-abortion people have decided
that the only way forward is to abandon
the fortress completely
give up on hookup culture
stop trying to have sex without
consequence and this is the right
response even if they don't have the
right motivations behind it
and who knows
maybe if they give up on hookup culture
you know
then they'll discover that that what
they were trying to protect themselves
from
is much better than what they were
trying to protect
perhaps they'll abandon their pursuit of
consequence-free loveless pointless sex
and learn to embrace the alternative
and the alternative is not celibacy but
a committed
faithful relationship with another human
being who you know and love and who
you've devoted yourself to through the
bonds of marriage and to whom you can
give yourself fully and completely
without fear or reservation
and and when you encounter the natural
consequence of sex the formation of a
new human life
you'll learn to see it not so much as a
consequence
but as a blessing
and a gift
with this perspective and this attitude
of true acceptance
you'll also experience what is known as
joy
which is something that you'll never
find
in hookup culture
which is anyway today cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matte wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike cormina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matt wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
a cnn commentator laments that the
repeal of roe means that it won't be as
easy to kill people with mental
disabilities aoc and maxine waters take
a break from investigating an
insurrection to instigating an
insurrection and the supreme court rules
in favor again today on on monday june
27th another major major win for the
constitution specifically for
conservatives and christians and
religious liberty check it out on the
michael knowles show